hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host grace helbig
and it is the last episode of not too
deep for the year 2021 so i thought how
fitting appropriate and sweet is it
to have
the one and only elliot morgan joined me
for this episode if you don't know
elliot morgan is my best friend and also
my fiance wow that's beautiful thank you
you're welcome
[Music]
hi thank you so much for being here
you've been a guest uh
one more than one time maybe one or two
times at least one time at least one
time yeah but you've been i think not by
yourself on the podcast sure okay right
we've done a separate one just the two
of us yeah we had a
short-lived fever-dreamish uh podcast
called pilot on we had a pandemic
podcast we had a pandemic podcast and
that's a sign that a podcast is really
going to stick when you decide to go for
it
in a time of uncertainty and turmoil hey
you know some podcasts go out with a
bang and ours went out with a nah not
really
oh yeah ours went out the way that you
snuff out a match
it's just very quiet how are you doing
grace i'm doing well thank you so much
for being here for elliott i don't
really have i know i i'm one i'm nervous
two i've already done all of the tropes
of not too deep with you on this podcast
before so we don't have anything
prepared um thought that this episode i
have a little bit of an interview um
with a company that i had talked to a
few months ago that we'll get to later
but i thought that maybe before that you
and i would just kind of have a casual
conversation
kind of wrapping up the year reflecting
on different variables throughout it etc
let's get into it okay
what do you do you want me to
start
i talked to you before this and i was
like i don't know what we should talk
about and you were like don't worry i'll
interview you yeah let's dive into it
grace how are you doing
deep down talk to me open up yeah do you
like it deep well do you like that
question because i do feel like i've
asked so many people
over the course of this year in so many
different ways how they're doing and i
do find that for different people
it's a very
it's a question that doesn't reveal how
they're doing but only reveals how ready
they are to talk about how they're doing
that's a great uh observation i have a
follow-up question about it yeah see how
i evaded that question by making this
and i love that i'm seeing now what
you've been doing on the whiteboard over
here which you guys can't see on camera
or certainly on audio but there is a ear
that has an arrow pointing out of it
that has a big dick yeah that's from a
live stream that memory knight did early
very funny okay so here's my question if
you were to mix up all of the answers
into a blender of when you've been
asking people how they're doing and pour
it into a big ol
reflective smoothie what would it taste
like
oh it would what's your vibe from the
amalgamation of the because you've
talked to a lot of people this year yeah
i think you have feedback on the general
a weird kind of
scientific qualitative not quantitative
i'm um
awful at
like
representing flavors self-talk so i
agree with representing flavors
someone that's uh primary grocery store
shopping occurs at 7-eleven
i would say
that it would be a flavor profile that
is confusing on the palette
where you can't really discern
what from what is their citrus is there
sweetness is there smokiness is there
one meatiness and then there's like a
bite afterwards
like a sharpness afterwards i think the
general at least from my talking to a
lot of different people that are artists
for the most part in different avenues
is that
everyone's
kind of in a
a moment of either
having pivoted
and knowing what they're doing and going
forward with something or kind of
figuring out what their pivot is right
now and i can relate going towards
something yeah
go on
no that's what i said
yeah if you can relate in what way can
you relate to that everything you said i
was like i can relate to that as you
burp inside of your own mouth truly okay
whatever i'll be very honest with you
guys we had uh it was my idea and we and
we're gonna get into new year's
resolutions in a little bit but we
ordered pizza last night yeah
uh and it ruined my next day it's uh a
very um
it's just indicative that sometimes as
you grow in life you have to change your
behaviors and mine has uh has def i've
gotten to that point and i feel very uh
physically today i felt very bad from an
excess amount of domino's pizza well i'm
thankful that you are able to muster up
enough energy to sit here and talk with
me about it
and to really reveal your truth and be
vulnerable with all of us how are you
doing great you can't keep coming back
to that you're not answering the
question the question is i think and
what i've heard from everyone
is fine
which is
no one wants to hear
fine it's not fun but it's honest is
that i'm fine yeah
i think
that everyone's like i said trying to
figure everything out and it's wild
times to figure everything out
how are you doing ellie fine babe i'm
fine i'm fine okay i'm fine and see when
you say that i say thank you so much for
telling me no i am a gr i am i you could
not imagine someone more right in
between good and bad okay i am i'm uh
the metronome just stopped in the middle
no no music the music is stopped
the rhythm of music is just playing one
note yep and it's like i have nothing to
complain about and i have nothing to go
oh boy this is exciting okay well except
for being you know i love you very much
and that's all great but you know we're
not getting into that like that's well
if we're going to get deep because
you've already um
kind of set that course for this
rambling bit
how do you think that you get out of
being
fine why do you need to get out of being
fine that's the other question do you
need to get out of it i don't think you
do okay in fact i think fine is what
many people would kill for really yeah
true who you know let's let them uh
let's let's let's embrace the uh the
fineness but uh you have to embrace the
contradiction of good and bad constantly
in every moment of life and that's my
big deep comment well i will say that
you and i have both decided heidegger
said no
well on that no ish you and i in the
last year
uh
plus have decided to go to grad school
and i get a lot of questions about
um making that decision
and how
and why um
and so i
turn those questions over to you as
someone that is currently in a phd
program
and who's you know on paper history of
comedy and entertainment and digital
creation doesn't necessarily lend itself
to that being the next step for you how
did you make that decision because i do
think a lot of people are making
decisions that feel
on paper very radically out of the path
that they've been in
that's a great question grace um and
it's a very it's a real yeah it's a real
question it's very complex answer so i'm
going to try to unpack it to the best of
my ability i would say that and i've
seen you unpack a suitcase and it
doesn't go away it's chaos absolutely
it's an explosion so here we go
uh i would say
the there it's a two-fold answer one is
that the most important one is i
followed
my gut and i followed my
what does that mean because that's like
a a phrase that i
hear i also pay attention to but it
sounds so you know
like a poetic throw away yeah i think
gut is when your inner um emotions and
your s your stomach and your pulse lines
up with what your brain is doing which
also lines up with what the outside
world is doing and so for me in the
moment of deciding to go to grad school
all those things lined up and i then
shot from the hip a little bit and so
that's the second part of it where i
would say following your gut is not
necessarily um
like the be-all and end-all of decision
making i think
following your gut is has a downside
where you have to then
go oh this is actually a big very
serious thing but i was very like this
makes sense i'm going to do this and
have faith that it's going to work and
then uh well having faith is a big part
of it too it is
it is a big part and so you go uh all
right let's see what happens and uh i've
lucked out a little bit um
in a way that has only affirmed my my
shooting from the hip but i would not
say that everyone should just shoot from
the hip constantly you're looking at
your gut your hip you're really
listening to
your hips what happens if they lie
get ready for my toes
when you're when you feel it in your
toes
uh yeah but it was truly like a um oh
and to be very honest i looked at i was
very um
i think that you have to have a c a
conscious awareness of uh you didn't
want this for your body no i do this is
the end of the year and this is
something that i haven't had a chance to
really kind of explain in depth um about
what our current like situations are
behind the scenes of
the limited things we post on the
internet now yeah i i very limited so
limited but i um i was very like uh
let's look at
be aware of the fact that you're going
to die one day as dark as that is and i
hate to bring it down on this uh episode
of not too deep but um
being aware that you have so many years
left to live and i was like what do i
want to do 10 years from now do i want
to be doing do i want to be going to
comedy clubs and trying to
write a funny thing or do i want to dive
into what something in my soul is saying
i should uh i should go for it and so i
went that direction and it was a very
like
okay i have this many years left on the
planet this is gonna take a lot of times
can take a lot of money and i'm gonna go
do it and see what happens because uh i
only have one life to live basically so
there's a little bit of weird nihilism
weird little bit of like okay let's do
this because um
uh they're wondering what if yeah yeah
and i don't want to be 10 years from now
i would hate to look back and go man i
could have like i could have i could
know about this stuff if i had really
studied it but i yeah but also you had
an interest already that was kind of
something you
indulge in in fundamentalists with peter
rollins and dr peter dr peterson so
angry if you don't call him
uh but it was already kind of like a
side passion
ish that was kind of
uh
like informally played around with that
you decided to take on more formally
yeah and and disagreeing with him on
certain levels and having no um ground
to stand on and being like man i don't
know enough i
feel a certain way about it but uh
being able to learn
from every angle has been uh
really just so great so yeah i have no
um yeah i mean i feel like
a lot of people are trying to make very
difficult decisions of entering into
something that
interests them or that you know stirs
their curiosity but there's no certainty
in what lies ahead if they decide to go
in that direction i think in this past
year and even going now into the new
year that's going to become way more
um prevalent for for people and
it's interesting to hear i think from
people that are doing it
well how how are you doing you're doing
it as well grace yeah yeah
program and it's interesting because we
joined separate programs in the same
school and they kind of complement each
other so we have a lot of similar um
the book lists will often have things
that one of us has
yeah and that's
so exciting like you're reading now um
or getting into a little bit of yoong's
red book which is really interesting and
i've had a whole class on redbook so
it's so fun well for people that don't
yeah for people that don't know we're in
a
programs how do you describe them
well you're in what's called engaged
humanities and creative life or
something like that so you're in an
arts-based program it's a master's
program yeah yeah and it's very
humanities-based i'm also in a
psychology program that it's a type of
psychology that is very based in kind of
art and uh creativity which is very fun
yeah like a typical psychology is very
based on like
and art
in art yeah
metaphors all of it i do think that when
you and i started dating it was already
very nice to have um the camaraderie of
youtube and digital content creation
within our like connection and then now
moving into this it's equally nice to
have the camaraderie of being in similar
complementary but different programs um
which is so fun it feels like cheating
in school to have someone in my house
that
has all the books and knows a little bit
more about what i'm learning about in my
program but i will say for me
to take the plunge to
decide
uh to sign up for this program was that
i mean i spent a few years feeling very
disenchanted
by what i was doing
um online and feeling very lost but
feeling like in the pressure to keep up
all the time so it's like this hamster
wheel of like
just is this how it's supposed to feel
like i don't know that it felt this way
and i have a hard time of um
committing to the feeling of burnout and
truly creating boundaries and commitment
in general and the uh like
deciding or recognizing when i need to
step away from something that is no
longer like serving me
especially when you feel
so
lucky to be working in such a
cool
new
art
platform digital like it just feeling
like you're on the forefront of
something and then feeling like it
doesn't connect with you ironically
in how much connection you have and
needing something else and also just
needing structure
um because working in a
you know online content creator capacity
you truly
lack structure unless you create it for
yourself and some people are very very
great at creating that for themselves
and i
had to recognize that i am not
people are really good at that uh one of
the things that i like about the
area of uh
depth psychology is the idea that your
uh symptoms your like tendencies to feel
certain things are more like
warning lights or or the you know um
dashboard kind of you know check engine
lights that pop up and uh when you talk
about like burnout and stuff i think
there's a loop you can get into where
you're like oh
i'm burnt out so that means i need to
pause and then do it all over again do
the same thing again and i'll feel
refreshed but doing the same thing yeah
but the burnout might be going like no
you we're done we're done with this now
like let's do something slightly
different do it in a different way and
that's a very fun it just gives you a
different way of looking at stuff which
i think is cool yeah and also just
having um so much momentum in one area
it's very hard to
like you said have faith that trying you
can gain momentum in another area yes
it's very terrifying all the time
every day
but i do think that
there's so many people out there that
are trying to figure out what their
pivot is without knowing and i'll tell
you
from my like point of view i'm over
halfway through this grad school uh
situation and i still have no real
clarity
on what i'm going to do
with this experience in grad school
because i think part of it i'm so
conclusions based that if i exactly
start something i want to know what the
benefit is i want to know what i will be
doing i want to know what script i'll be
writing what book i'll be writing what
thing i'll be doing i'm gonna go ahead
i know
dominating your psych there's many
voices it was so hard for me to
recognize that i'm a person that is so
desiring of certainty
and
uh
because i thought people that were
neurotically desiring with certainty
were like uncool
and
to quote luanne deliceps uh don't be all
uncool well i was all uncool and so
i i and i but i i think the cool thing
is like free falling into something that
resonates with your gut like you were
saying earlier and then recognize that
something in you wanted that and got it
so it's and that you have to be in it
you have to be in the uncertainty and
the weird
cloudy uh part of it and try to have
faith that there's something on the
other side that's important
yes
mostly
but also don't do it for the faith and
don't worry about the fake okay well
look if you want to get into it
to quote limb biscuit you gotta have
faith wait to quote limb biscuit
kind of faith is fine
okay we're gonna take a quick break and
we'll be right back with more not too
deep with elliott morgan and some other
stuff
[Music]
hello listeners grace helbig here
wanting to say two things a big thank
you for listening to the podcast uh if
you're a regular listener if this is
your first time listening welcome and
thank you
and uh second thing if you are enjoying
yourself here in this not too deep world
we've built and you'd like to leave us a
review that would be so wonderful if you
can go to the itunes store the app store
and leave us a lovely little review
comment how are you feeling good bad
otherwise maybe just good or otherwise
would be appreciated other than that
enjoy the podcast
and we're back hi
um now we've talked about how we've
gotten
into grad school being in grad school
maybe we move away from grad school a
little bit and just talk about generally
moving into 20
22.
well okay let's dive into it great
because this is the last episode of 2021
which i feel like was an accordion you
know it started real slow and then it's
like it's got squeezed and all of a
sudden the poker song came on and it
went real fast
spoke it was like a bogus song yeah yeah
has been focused that's very funny yeah
uh okay so let's talk about new year's
resolutions all right so yeah i haven't
really thought
i i don't necessarily think through new
year's resolutions every year i used to
try and do it a little bit but that's
also just me loving fresh starts exactly
um but do you have new year's
resolutions so many really okay
okay i use it as a checklist for all the
things i want to change about my life so
it's very long okay all right can you
give us like what are your top three to
five okay well first though let me just
say something about new year's
resolutions yeah which is uh i'm a big
fan because i think it's very rare that
you have a chance to
to just
it's very rare that we collectively have
a reason to be like okay let's restart a
little bit i think it's beautiful oh you
mean that it's socially
i like it acceptable like it's it's the
social current the same way i like
christmas and how it's a holiday because
you can restart whenever you want right
but when else is everyone kind of
thinking the same thing but that's my
question okay that's my question is that
does that matter i think it does okay i
think it's nice i think it's one of the
few kind of rituals we have left uh in
this uh
this hellscape
but i love the idea of just being like
let's let's switch things up and and
doing it together and people always go
well you never keep them yeah keep the
resolutions but i say uh let's um
give it a shot and so here's what you're
writing yeah okay all right
no mcdonald's
norm mcdonald's norm mcdonald's yeah
uh no mcdonald's no no
no taco bell no fast food or just those
two particular fast foods well here's
the deal
sometimes you want comfort food right
mm-hmm so i think that there's ways
around getting i love fasting but
comfort food can be slow cooked food
exactly okay
that's exactly what i'm saying so what
are you saying what are you saying i'm
saying no taco bell no mcdonald's no
fast comfort food
well okay so i gotta be very specific
kfc myself popeyes
del taco i didn't say any of those
things jack in a box all allowed those
are all allowed i'm saying that these
particular foods because these are your
these are your number ones and twos
right they give you the twos and twos
yeah
okay
yeah
so i say no mcdonald's no taco bell no
dominoes based on recent events
okay uh but here's the deal there's two
different types of resolutions there's
withdrawal
and there's addition
okay the withdrawal is easy i can take
things away okay
but the addition is the difficult part
so what do you want to add in the new
year for me that's just constant uh
exercise so my goal is to for a year
work out
five to seven
days a week wow yeah because i was doing
that for a while and it was great and i
love what do you think about
did i miss it so i i know i can do it so
i want to keep keep doing it right here
here's my follow-up question to that
i i have
concern or curiosity about the idea of
not for you in particular but in general
for people that make resolutions that
seem to take them from zero to 60 in
what their lifestyle had been and that
to me seems
what makes resolutions not sustainable
is that when you make a complete about
face
and you change your lifestyle abruptly
and unsustainable and how can you you
can maintain that for a little bit but
then you become so
well here's okay so all right because
that feels like all on paper all sounds
cool here's my general theory with new
year's resolutions uh if you can make it
two months in any of them
uh i count that as a win i'm like you
did it and so it's a year's over so by
march you're back on taco bell no
working out i understand if you have two
months and then though so you're a
pendulum no ma'am no ma'am i see what
you're doing and no ma'am
you you do it for that amount of time
and then you assess and you go do i want
to keep doing this for myself is it is
my life better as a result of doing this
for the past two months
and then you're no longer doing it
because it's new year's resolution
you're doing it because you've seen
you've reaped the rewards of having some
discipline in your life or i think we
can both agree
me having discipline in my life is not
the worst case scenario i i whatever
discipline looks like for you that makes
sense
i can't make those decisions for you
i just think that knowing myself if i go
in one direction and then extreme swing
past back to the other direction
i'm not how do i sustain a middle ground
it's all beautiful you know
swings
but so are you okay so when you think
about new year's resolutions do you
think about them
solely existing in the new ish part of
the year and then the rest of the year
or do you think about new year's
resolutions to sustain throughout the
course of the year because i do think
people
forget that new year's resolutions
they only keep them in the new part of
the year because it's in the title of
what they're deciding for themselves
if they decide
year-long resolutions if we had it as
year-long resolutions i think that might
make people think a little bit
differently about what they mean versus
new year's resolutions okay
all i i'm just saying all i know
is that if you give yourself a little
bit of a
runway
in celebration of the new year then your
motivations might change as a result of
those decisions but you i agree that the
you can't remain motivated as a result
of being like
this is my
new year's resolution
let me go ahead and
scratch one of my questions right now
which one i'm gonna be very honest with
you which one i'm not getting at
mcdonald's
you're not gonna give up mcdonald's
breakfast mcdonald's is one of the
greatest but you only have it that i
know of like once every couple months
unless there's some other shenanigans
going on
well here's what i might say something
very controversial here
i think
at least for me
that new year's resolutions are a bit
[ __ ]
because i am someone that loves the
opportunity for
what i have now learned for myself are
superficial fresh starts and the idea of
like the collective freshly starting and
all these apps and all of these things
and all these discounted exercise
equipments and food plans and all of
this are wonderful at the start of the
year and you do feel the collective
energy of it all but then you also feel
the collective drain of it all by
february or march and it seems like if
you want to make something
for yourself
that changes or sticks you have to do it
at a time in which you are ready to take
on that major change or
stickiness well maybe
i'm just saying i used to love
and still idolize like the fantasy of
new year's resolutions because it feels
like this gimmicky thing you do
but i have never a fantasy i do not know
that any of them have ever stuck for me
in previous years so they don't resonate
with me as something did goose fart
because it smells awful and i didn't
know if your dominos was still having a
moment wow yeah that's incredible yeah
i'm really so bad that is uh
truly uh she's down there okay one for
the record books
uh anyway oh god i was gonna say uh if i
may
she i think she agrees with me is what
she's trying to say yeah well what i was
gonna say was maybe your new year's
resolution
should be
to not be so cynical
about new year's resolutions it's not
cynicism it's stupid it's not let's see
but that's the thing yeah that's wrong
with being stupid
i didn't think anything was wrong with
them i just think for myself
if i want to make changes that are real
the way that people treat resolutions
like i got to do it
at any point not necessarily in the
beginning of january that aligns with me
when i'm ready to take them on right in
a perfect world you wake up tomorrow and
you go i'm going to give up taco bell
but
you know you're not going to do that and
so it helps to have a collective holiday
where the entire okay all around you
rests and goes what are we going to
change about it's just a nice it's a
nice reset well then other than taco
bell and exercise
which i think are very
traditional types of resolutions for
people what's like your third resolution
well this brings up a great point grace
yeah which is i believe that there is a
value in um
certain resolutions being uh secret very
private okay yeah because i agree then
you don't
you're not saying it on a podcast and
feeling some sort of big social pressure
yeah accountability i mean
i think the biggest accountability is
when you're it's just yourself because
there's no bigger disappointment than
when you're just like man i really had
don't no one was even asking me and i
still screwed it up
well okay
you're anticipating failure
and you're gonna keep it private so that
you get to be your own worst enemy
private for so long what are you going
to do i mean do you want to know i don't
know anything it's a fun con it's a
contest with yourself
what i will
continue to do um i think is
pay attention
to my mental health which is i think you
know very trendy now whatever but i do
think for myself i've i've been
internally making some strides in
different directions and i'm like i said
earlier one of those people that wants
to get to the conclusion of it and i
kind of need to sit with myself on
different things and i want to
enjoy the rest of my graduate program
that i have i really want to like spend
time there working on and through the
stuff that i'm i'm learning about
it's very fun to see you uh
spend many weeks going
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm doing
i get this and i have something to
contribute and then ninety percent of
the time i'm like what the [ __ ] is all
of this and why the [ __ ] do we need to
learn all of this and then i realized i
signed myself up into this and i am the
one that has put myself in this
situation you're doing great stuff you
too
well we have to wrap this up um is there
anything else that you'd like to say
i mean i love you thank you
i think you were really great all right
and um i can't wait for all of us to be
monitoring
and tweeting at you and messaging you
and checking in with you all through the
course of january february and maybe
into march about your relationship with
taco bell mcdonald's and exercise i took
mcdonald's off the table
well
thank you elliot for being here and i
hope you guys enjoy um this interview
that i did months ago with the uh
team behind psychedelic water ever heard
of it
well maybe you should take a listen and
we'll see you in the new year
thanks for listening
goodbye
okay okay you did it thank you so much
thank you
[Music]
okay this is unlike any episode i think
i've ever done on not too deep but i am
very excited to talk about things that
fascinate me and uh that i i'd love to
hear uh all of your responses and ideas
behind first of all
can you introduce yourselves as uh who
you are and what it is you do for
psychedelic water
my name is ben rogel um i am the
marketing director at psychedelic water
um you know i've been around since uh
day one pretty much okay and uh which is
in february so you're still under a year
old right okay
yeah well we officially launched in
february but there was a lot of work
behind the scenes before we actually
uh were able to launch our product got
it
yeah
and brittany what is your relationship
to this experience
yes so um i've been working with
psychedelic water for a couple months
now um
i am building content with them and also
getting the word out about the product
um getting to talk to people on the
streets over here in san diego and
letting them know about this product
cool
very grassroots and speaking of
getting on the streets keith is a
man about town on the street
just so you know if you can hear me i'll
be i won't be walking in a moment but
i'm i'm the founder of psychedelic water
um and i'm sort of the og of the company
as you can see okay
very cool
uh this is what an og does he doesn't
stop it's always hustle
i have okay i have so much curiosity one
i'd love to hear ben and brittany kind
of your origin story of how did you get
involved in this product and on top of
that
you know it's such a um
if
a
triggering is not the right word but
it's such a excitable kind of concept uh
how do you describe it to someone that
has absolutely no idea what this product
is or what the mission kind of is behind
the product so
yeah you know what it's it's there's
nothing else
like it
out there right um the feeling of
psychedelic water it's
to me it's this it's a mild sort of mood
booster makes you feel sort of chill
that makes you feel really good
um and so
you know i
personally like i drink it
very frequently because we have a good
supply of it yeah um
and it you know a lot of it for me it
depends on my mood sometimes i'll have
one in the morning before work okay um
you know if i have a busy day ahead and
i need to sort of calm myself down sure
then i'll have one before work um
there are times where maybe it's a
thursday as well i'm meeting up with
friends after
instead of you know there's no hangovers
with it so if i want to feel okay on
friday yeah so basically so like the
brass tacks of what this product is is a
like a liquid herbal supplement of of
sorts to try and kind of
regulate and calm anxieties and and the
like for sure does that great let me
tell you something when i came up with
this idea when i came up with this idea
two years ago yeah i was really involved
i'm still really involved in the
cannabis industry right yeah
and i love that sector but i was
thinking there's got to be a cannabis
2.0 or 3. 3.0 so years ago i started
researching psychedelics and i thought
okay this is the next frontier
i believe that psychedelics
will change the world way more
ultimately than cannabis it's just it
can it's just so powering so powerful
and the impact the psychedelics will
have over the next five years
you ain't seen nothing yet
okay
and i'm i'm a cannabis fan sure but when
i started when i started researching it
i said how the [ __ ] am i gonna do this
yeah because it's illegal everywhere
right right and i'm an entrepreneur so i
can't start a business
that is going to be put out of business
i hired so i hired a food scientist
professor from nyu and a formulation
company out of california i said here's
the mandate okay i want to launch the
world's first psychedelic brand
but i want it to be something i can
bring into the mainstream and i had a
couple of goals i didn't only want to
create a product
i wanted to build a company around a
certain ethos
something that would i wanted to support
psychedelic thinking and what we're
talking about is the psychedelic state
of mind you know there's certain people
who are just closed-minded yeah and
there's certain people who are
groundbreakers
mavericks risk takers curious
adventurous passion about life yeah to
me
that is what a psychedelic state of mind
is so i always think about you know
steve jobs
you know he actually did psychedelics
yeah he was a psychedelic dude yeah
billy billy eilish whether she does
psychedelics or not she's like there's
certain people like you grace are
psychedelic well look i'll
this is why i'm fascinated to talk to
you guys because i there's no i've
talked about this in previous podcasts
on other situations that i'm no stranger
to mushrooms and i'm no stranger to an
actual psychedelic experience in fact
one of the most profound experiences
that i had on mushrooms while i was in
college uh was that i wanted to make
people laugh and it
kind of catalyzed me to pursue comedy in
general and so i think
when um
kind of
take it in the right sort of like
respectful way and handle it in a
more kind of elevated situation that it
has truly profound effects on people
like you're saying opening up avenues of
the brain
allowing in love and care and connection
in ways that is impossible to explain in
everyday life to anyone
like i'm looking at the elmo on your
shelf bed and i feel like yeah that is a
bit of a
symbolic uh gesture of the kind of
feeling you can get from this situation
well that's also my childhood heart yeah
okay
but that's why it's so because this is
such a i guess stigmatized area to be
able to kind of like dilute it into more
mainstream i'm so curious about how you
guys approach all of that that's why
it's it's very interesting to talk news
that we're demystified yeah that's a key
priority so
one of the first things i did when i
came up with the idea was i started
thinking about the trademark and i
couldn't believe it that nobody on the
word psychedelic was psychic water i was
shocked
so
we spent hundreds of thousands of
dollars
trademarking
the word psychedelic and the words
psychedelic water around the world so
we're not only on those trademarks by
the way yeah but i thought okay i'm not
trying to create a one-trick pony
company here this company is going to be
far more than just our our existing
products which are amazing one day we'll
have we could have 20 or 30 different
products and we're going to stand for
more than just products so we also
trademark psychedelic coffee psychedelic
tea psychedelic energy any derivative
that would make sense to you yeah or
that you would probably guess that we
own um so step one was
getting that trademark because our
thinking was
we've got we've got
a bit of a mountain to climb here there
are a lot of psychedelic haters because
they're cause-minded people and there's
also the legal landscape which makes no
sense yeah it has to change because
anybody who wants to do magic mushrooms
you can have them at your door in 30
minutes
if you talk to anyone under the age of
30 they've either tried psychedelics
they've dabbled they've experimented or
they're thinking about trying it
so there's this reality on the ground
and then there's the legal landscape
which is a complete disconnect so my
objective and our company's objective
was to insert psychedelics into everyday
life how do we do that
if you can walk if you can go into a
convenience store or a gas station and
you see something called psychedelic on
the shelf or psychedelic water on the
shelf yeah that's step one in our
mission to demystify and normalize
psychedelics
i mean and then you have people like
rachel ray talking about it right so i
think that's gonna
that's a big conduit to get into the
middle america families but i'm curious
brittany from your perspective as like
an influencer that's trying to like you
know kind of embody this message and
also
market it in so many ways like how did
you first get involved in this company
was this something that you found
interesting and reached out because i
know that you do a lot of like yoga
lifestyle stuff
yeah so for pretty much all my life i've
been really into being healthy even when
i was younger i rather eat like
veggies and fruits over candy and all of
that
i've always had like a health conscious
mind and gravitated towards like more
natural products
and um i recently started to
um do yoga
not recently but yoga teacher training
and then getting my license and all of
that and i was on tick tock and saw this
product and i
you know dabble it with um micro dosing
mushrooms sometimes and then also the
big craze right now is mushroom products
all the lattes that are coming out yeah
um so i really knew a lot of information
on the medicinal mushrooms
along with like the psilocybin so when i
saw this product i was so curious about
it because
of the name but knowing what else is in
there
the cava
damiana and green tea which making it a
psychedelic blend that doesn't like make
you hallucinate or anything but it kind
of relaxes you is something that i
gravitated more towards because i suffer
from anxiety and stuff
so when i drink it it really like calms
me down
and um and plus their instagram our
instagram and tick tock is really pretty
amazing and creative and i'm going to
create a person along with my boyfriend
we work together we make like creative
content yeah so we're like oh my gosh we
need to make something for this brand
and then we did and then got involved
with them and it's been really cool ever
since
and then just talking about the product
and trying to get it out there has been
great too because everybody is curious
about it yeah i think that i mean i
was so curious to talk to you guys about
it because i think people it provokes an
interest of oh this is something that
can help me manage or you know combat my
anxieties on a regular level but all
i've maybe heard is negative uh
commentary around it
how do i kind of manage my expectations
of this how do i manage my experience
and my curiosities around it i'm curious
what the biggest kind of
thing for you guys other than
trademarking psychedelic and psychedelic
water like what's the biggest question
that you all get asked as people that
work for this company in this product
great so first if i can just
sidebar for a second yeah around
brittany because she did something that
i think influencers out there
influencers should really take note of
she she and her boyfriend made these
great videos
created this great content without ever
being on our payroll they were just so
excited and they loved the product so
much and it came to our attention and we
said
[ __ ] yeah these people are great we even
if we didn't care if they had the
following or anything we just loved they
were authentic yeah they were into
traditional psychedelic and they loved
our product
and that's how the working relationship
started i wish more influencers would
actually
try to put some stuff out there for show
your
show a connection to the product yeah
because good good things will follow and
we pay many input we pay you know tens
of thousands of dollars to influencers
that's that's part of the game anyway
back to
some of the some of the challenges we
faced
this is the first product of its kind so
we're pioneering here and when you're a
pioneer
you're going to get blow back
this is this this is the most
psychedelic product we could create
without going to jail
if we wanted to actually you know people
call [ __ ] that's that should be the
log line of the product i don't know why
that's not on the boxes
we have 40 000 customers have already
bought this product we know what their
reaction is they're telling us to get a
mood boost it kills them out they feel
happier more content
we've had you know
brit talked about her her anxiety
we've had this whole constituency of
young females out there who suffer from
anxiety who've really embraced our
product and they've been just
such a disparate group of people who've
supported us for example mma fighters
yeah without us ever talking they
started reaching out to us and saying
we're using your product because it
helps us get through workouts really
intense workouts it takes the hedgehog
but look if people are out there and we
tell them if you're looking for some
face melting experience
this is not the product we're trying to
bring psychedelics to the mainstream you
will feel better
but
it doesn't contain psilocybin as i said
it's as psychedelic as a product can get
today gotcha yeah it's not um whatever
divine experience you might have while
consuming the product might be
part to your own experience and not the
actual water i'm so concerned well i'm
also curious brittany you talk about the
tick tock of it all and this is like um
you know a very viral product uh but the
way you guys talk about it you want this
to have long-term
success so how do you kind of combat
the idea that this is just like a trend
that people will pick up on tick tock
and start trying because they see it
show up in their algorithm versus like
trying to have like the longevity of the
product and the line itself
yeah i mean i think the product when you
look at it you're just like what is that
everything about it it just stands out
if it's the right direction
and um
so that just like catches your eye off
the bat but once you drink it and you
start to feel the effects that it
actually gives off into your body it's
something that you
you know it hits your tongue and your
tongue starts to
tangle yeah the kava in it and you're
like oh there is something in here
that's magical and then even if it's
more of like you know there's something
good in it but you know that it's doing
good hitting your tongue going into your
belly and it creates something in your
mind that makes you feel good it makes
you feel better you know even if it is
like you know placebo with whatever what
is in here the different
supplements
but placebo to us is a bad word because
we're anything but
a placebo
that i drink red bull constantly and
that also has uh tongue numbing effects
and some warmness in my belly but i
don't think it's doing anything good for
me at the end of the day so i feel like
you guys are kind of combating this idea
of creating something that has uh a
subtlety to it i mean ben you said you
drink it if you're having a meeting
happening that you need to be a little
more mellowed out for i i always have
cans close by yeah always so this is
something that like people don't need to
be kind of shocked or afraid that this
is not something they could incorporate
into their daily lives well i think
people kind of should bring it into
their daily life yeah you know be like
with with so many moving people pieces
in
society with you know
careers and trying to keep up with
social life and instagram social media
like like why not have something that
can take that edge off and incorporate
it into your daily life
do you now see in the marketplace uh
competing products that are trying to
kind of
assimilate what you are doing or or have
done
not yet but there will there will be
copycats you know we've become in a
short time probably the number one
consumer-facing psychedelic brand in the
world uh so we've we've got this head
start um
and we we intend to use it to get to get
bigger fast yeah and also work on the
regulatory front we're going to start
working with american politicians in the
new year because we're trying to promote
decriminalization of psychedelics and
psilocybin wow and also promote one day
legalization that day will come we're
probably um five to ten years away from
legalization but there will be
exceptions for therapeutic use the
psychedelics i said will change the
world so the legal side of things must
change to accommodate that reality wow
these are
big
big ideas on the horizon for you guys
world-changing stuff we've reached the
end of the podcast i could talk to you
guys uh so much i feel like i'm getting
just free business advice from everyone
i'm so fascinated and excited about the
products plural that are in the pipeline
um before you guys all jump off we like
to show our appreciation uh for you guys
making time and we have created a
personalized horoscope um from us to you
and it's we've used the birth date of
the company itself uh to create this
horoscope
and so any of you can jump in melissa
just put it in the chat if you'd like to
read that horoscope aloud for the class
dear aquarius water bearer of the stars
venus and sagittarius squares neptune in
uh pisces this week which may put some
pressure on your wallet
and your desire to have fun remember the
big picture and save away that money for
something important in the future such
as psychedelic water at coachella just
to watch post malone somehow mellow out
even more backstage
it's in the stars it's in the stars for
you guys there it is
uh okay before we wrap up completely
where can people find psychedelic water
where can they find and follow the new
products that will be coming out in the
future if they don't already know
psychedelicwater.com
just like that so easy so easy and is it
best for them to go online and order
online if they're interested
yeah we'll be in a couple thousand
stores next year but the simplest way
for most people across the country is go
straight to
psychedelicwater.com check us out on
instagram or tick tock wherever but
psycneticwater.com is the easiest place
to buy it great awesome thank you guys
so much for this well-rounded
conversation from all avenues of the
business i feel very informed now
i really appreciate it ben brittany
keith thank you guys go check out
psychedelicwater.com if you guys are at
all interested it's worth your time it's
worth what else do you have to lose
other than some anxiety i guess uh we'll
see you guys next time on not too deep
goodbye
too deep too deep too deep
not too deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis post
production sound by chris henry and an
extra special thanks to flula for the
theme music